Keanu Reeves in the Marvel Cinematic Universe?
It could happen, and some people are refusing
to give up the ghost.
Keanu Reeves is easily one of the most recognizable
action movie stars alive today, and for good
reason.
The "John Wick" movies have enjoyed monumental
success for being ultra-violent, ultra-entertaining
thriller films.
Overall, all three films have grossed $573
million worldwide and a fourth film is on
the way.
More recently, Reeves starred in the long-awaited
fourth entry in "The Matrix" franchise, "The
Matrix Resurrections."
Through all this, fans have been wondering
when Reeves would become involved in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
After all, it wouldn't be his first time stepping
into a comic book property.
He could previously be seen in the titular
role in 2005's "Constantine," based on the
DC Comics property.
Reeves has confirmed that he's met with Marvel
Studios president Kevin Feige, but so far,
they've been unable to come up with a way
to bring the actor into the fold.
Of course, where there's a will there's a
way.
Naturally, viewers have bided their time by
fan-casting him in many roles, and one of
the more popular dream-casts for Reeves is
that of Ghost Rider.
Luckily for those fans, some crafty digital
artists have imagined what Reeves could potentially
look like in the role.
Late last year, artist @MizuriAU posted some
fanart of Keanu Reeves with half of his face
engulfed in flame and showcasing the trademark
Ghost Rider skull.
From the leather jacket, it seems clear that
this particular piece of art is meant to portray
Reeves as the Johnny Blaze incarnation of
the character.
Based on the art alone, the casting of Reeves
seems almost like a no-brainer for a "Ghost
Rider" do-over, especially following the poor
reception of the Nicolas Cage "Ghost Rider"
films.
Still, there's no guarantee that Reeves will
ever step into that role, especially given
his busy schedule with the "John Wick" movies
and whatever else he has in the pipeline.
Furthermore, "The Walking Dead" star Norman
Reedus has shown a lot of interest in the
role as of late, prompting rumors that the
part may already be his.
Of course, Mizuri made a mockup of what that
might look like, too.
Either way, it would be exciting for the MCU
to continue pushing in a darker direction
with "Ghost Rider."
If the upcoming release of the "Moon Knight"
series is any indication, Marvel seems more
willing to take things closer to the edge.
Alas, MCU fans hoping for concrete news regarding
the future of the Ghost Rider character will
have to continue to be patient.
Given his massive popularity, it should come
as no surprise that fans will take any excuse
to have more Keanu Reeves in their lives.
Even if it doesn't work out with Ghost Rider,
there are thousands of characters across the
pages of Marvel Comics, and surely, there's
a part out there for Reeves.
He may be nearly 60, but he still has the
star power to put butts in the seats.
As such, numerous artists have envisioned
what the actor could look like as a variety
of characters who have still yet to appear
in the MCU.
One Instagram artist that goes by the handle
@daanesh95, offered a glimpse of what he would
look like as Namor the Sub-Mariner.
There has been intense speculation that Namor
could make an appearance in "Black Panther
2," but those have yet to be confirmed.
It would undoubtedly be challenging to hide
Reeves' casting if that's the case, so perhaps
it's possible Namor will make his debut in
a later MCU project.
That same account also posted some artwork
of Reeves as a character we know he won't
appear as.
Years ago, Daanesh offered a portrait of Reeves
as Adam Warlock.
We now know that that character will appear
in "Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3," as played
by Will Poulter.
Reeves certainly would've been an excellent
pick for that part, but it wasn't meant to
be.
That's not even getting into all of the iconic
characters Reeves could theoretically play
one day, like Silver Surfer, Wonder Man, or
Nova.
An actor of his talents could portray virtually
anyone, and fans would be utterly delighted.
Then again, Reeves is a busy man these days,
so perhaps a multi-picture contract with Marvel
would be too difficult to pull off.
Still, there's nothing wrong with a little
hope.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.